[Music]
hey you people what's going on you
people
yeah so uh we're doing uh we're doing
one on this on this samurai program this
that we saw the other day it was good we
watched the samurai program
i wanted to make an announcement though
before we started the show um
on youtube five days ago uh
billiardo released a new video it's
called bitter i think it's called bitter
taste
it's really good yeah
and there's something about it i think
he's kind of going out the way bowie's
going out he's looking kind of skinny
and it's a death song oh so i it's you
know not confirmed but
i suspect that
that this is going to be his last album
and he's going out like a g his song's
really good it's almost like a chris
isaac sounding song
oh i like that yeah it's almost kind of
like a mixture of chris isaac and uh
maybe like
um
thinking
roy orbison or something
it's rock but it's kind of it's kind of
you'll see it's good yeah yeah it's real
good but he's looking kind of skinny
makes me think you know maybe
they're gonna make an announcement i
don't know you know how bowie went out
he didn't tell anybody what the hell was
going on and then put out all these damn
creepy videos going out like a g and
then a few days later turns out
he died yeah
he announced that he was dying well he's
dying he's making a video yeah i mean
you know we don't we don't know what to
do we'll just see i haven't seen the
video so i don't know what he looks like
yeah a lot of death imagery that's what
the the lyrics are about we're gonna see
hmm
that is kind of creepy yeah in the end
he's dressed like an angel laying dead
on the ground and [ __ ]
oh okay well that's
that's pretty uh yeah straightforward
all right
i hope you're okay billy yeah
but it's a great song though yeah i
don't i'm gonna have to look that up
it's good yeah
but yeah so we just kind of stumbled
across this is new right this is 2021
right um i don't know if they're going
to make more seasons they just listed as
season one probably i mean because it
seemed like they could pick up from
because this covers a pretty brief
uh you know this this covers uh you know
what like 15 50 to like yeah not long
that like the
first quarter like the 17th century
maybe it just talks about the how japan
became unified but goku period
yeah but there's a lot of stuff that
happened after this
you know what i mean it didn't get
peaceful
not forever a bunch of [ __ ] happens
later on
um
you know that you have the whole uh edo
period then the tokugawa period and
everything goes on and then eventually
you start going into the you can even go
into the republic period in japan that
was back in the in in the 1700s early
1800s weird [ __ ] happened then too where
they were fighting that
fighting the samurai get rid of the old
system
so a bunch of
japan had an interesting history
yeah and i didn't really know i mean i
knew a little bit about this from like
you know movies and
[ __ ] i remember from school and
everything but it's kind of cool
to see something like this just like
laid out
and i like that they did it it's not
just like a documentary so much like
just talking heads although they do have
that
but they have a lot of like reenactments
which i thought was like really cool and
yeah that was honestly that's the best
thing i like that they had like the
talking of like all the historians and
stuff i like that they had them all in
this like really nice like black and
white i thought that was like pretty
classy and then all the animation like
in between like all the maps and
everything where they're showing like
who owns what territory and stuff yeah
the battle maps all look like japanese
stuff from the 1500s it's just like all
this like spreading ink and stuff like
that it's really really like photographs
[ __ ] appearing on parchment and then
like spreading ink spreading into them
and just really good with a good uh
score in the back you know which is kind
of like a mixture of
old traditional japanese sound and stuff
mixed with metal and [ __ ] classical
music it's it's a good series it's kind
of like watching game of thrones
but it's a documentary so much beheading
yes just so much better just the way
they did things [ __ ] cutting people's
heads off [ __ ] viewing some heads and
rituals
yeah how people uh cutting your like
disemboweling yourself yeah which is a
pretty hardcore i gotta say yeah how
wives betrayed people and then sometimes
wives were good with you know they were
all these arranged marriages and then uh
lots of lots of concubines and uh
people people being born by the wrong
mama just it's it's a lot of a lot of
weird [ __ ] dudes that were peasants
rising shout outs
shout out to lady cha-cha yeah lady
cha-cha
it was one of the concubines yeah it's a
actually she wasn't a concubine was she
yeah yeah yeah she was a concubine yeah
yeah
she was just the one that finally like
gave the gave birth to the to the air
you
know
didn't have one yet yeah because he had
one by his wife but then they'd well no
the concubine had one but then he died
and then like he had another one though
but then he was just a kid you know what
i mean so yeah so this covers the period
i think it starts in like 1550 1551
something like that and then like when
there was no unified anything it was all
just warlords yeah daimyos they were
warlords fighting over japan it's just
big organized crime syndicates basically
yeah warring factions
it's real interesting the japanese the
chinese and the koreans to certainly
were extremely warlike they're not
you look at japan today you know you
look at tokyo and their [ __ ] cosplay
and anime and [ __ ] that's not who they
were you know
um
and that went right up until the second
world war
and the reason why they're not like that
anymore is just because i just think
they just
the guys that were like that all got
killed they all died
um well like i said dur
during this period because you have to
think too that you know the the
documentary and like i said i think it's
six episodes yeah yeah so it's like six
45-minute episodes something like that
and um so they kind of
stress this a lot like during the
documentary that
you know this
civil war was going on for like 150
years yeah so yeah so they're like
generations of people just grew up and
that's all they knew was just like
[ __ ]
killing everybody
and they were you know pretty advanced
in terms of the technology that they
made and even some of the thinking was
pretty advanced
advanced art and advanced
philosophies and stuff
but uh you know
the concept of bushido wasn't around
they didn't really have honor as you
know would know it today uh
then honor was killing was was winning
and to win a lot of times you had to
slaughter entire families
you couldn't allow a single heir to
survive and
you know yeah man they were whacking
each other's like brother's heads off
and [ __ ] like that
thinking about it they would go into
disobedient provinces that had been
independent and self-ruling for 150
years and just slaughter them all down
to all the men the women and the
children just genocides they did that to
ega i think is what it was
there was a mountain yeah that mountain
yeah it was just like a really small
kind of like and they'd all just come
and they were all like uh guerilla
warriors in there and they wouldn't let
anybody come through there they didn't
really have any
they didn't have a warlord in charge of
them they was self-governess this it's
kind of it was kind of like described as
maybe a democracy where they just kind
of voted and got together and kind of
decided what they were going to do
but they were also kind of like pirates
uh that's where they they think that the
stories of the ninja came from those
guys and they were just mountain
gorillas
uh which they use the word in english
gorilla a lot that is not what that is
the improper phrase it came from the
word gaheda which means warrior
in
spanish and it just got mistranslated as
gorilla into english it does not has
nothing to do with the great apes it
just meant war
well it just didn't spell different yeah
tactics just means warrior tactics
instead of soldier tactics you know
terrorism you know
uh yeah wolf whisperer says if you want
to hear from the people who worked on
this series there's a podcast called
samurai podcast with people who worked
on the series okay not a plug just a
recommendation yeah that might be worth
uh listening to hopefully there's
another season i could i could watch a
bunch of seasons of this yeah me too and
he's saying it too because that we were
talking about how like wiping out the
whole families wasn't really that
unusual but he's like oda nobunaga who
was like the first kind of warlord that
they talked about um you know he started
in awarie right and then like kind of
spread outward from there um but wolf
whisperer said he was uh reminded me of
a japanese vlad the impaler not gonna
lie yeah he was kind of like that and
and like i said all of the kind of
the warlords and stuff were obviously um
you know violent and went to war all the
time and like killed their relatives and
[ __ ] like that but the [ __ ] that
nobunaga did
even some of his own like samurais and
generals and stuff were like bro yeah
let's like so let's back that up yeah he
used a lot of terror tactics
hands off and stuff for everybody women
children when he didn't really have to
well and the thing about it is that
ended up biting him in the ass in the
end because like there was so much um
rebellion against him because yeah you
know you you do [ __ ] like that people
gonna hate you yeah then later on
another guy appears i forgot what his
name is his lieutenant he didn't like
all that [ __ ] that was going on he was
more of a mixture of
and and really the guys who in periods
like this who tend to rise to the top
are guys that can
use force of violence and politics they
use the they use the the stick and the
carrot
um because that's a lot more effective
if if you have a guy who's utterly
ruthless you have to fight to the death
because if you surrender to him he kills
you
so it's not a good idea to kill people
who surrender to you if they surrender
let them surrender
that means in the future you don't have
to fight
everybody they'll just surrender to you
yeah because eventually you go around
being enough of the dick everybody's
gonna turn against you
yeah because the second you jump on them
they have to fight to the death because
they know they're gonna be executed yeah
so they just fight against you harder
you know so you don't want to do that
you want
you want to to show that
if you
if you disobey you're punished
if you fight hard
you'll be punished but if you surrender
you're rewarded that's always you got to
grease the wheels
you know and if you surrender you'll be
treated fairly you know [ __ ] even
cyrus the great knew that and that goes
went back thousands of years ago
you always want to come in as a
liberator not a conqueror so much easier
like osiris the great just run into a
damn
kingdom and [ __ ] the
the the enemy army would [ __ ] revolt
against their own king and join cyrus
because they knew they were going to get
a good deal
yeah so when cyrus showed up you know
it was better to be with him than your
despotic king usually because he'd give
you human rights and stuff and you know
allow you to conduct business
uh would not over tax you wouldn't tell
you what religion to worship
so it's always better to be
flexible let people be who they are
if you start trying to change people's
culture that bite you in the ass which
that's what's happening right now in
afghanistan i [ __ ] i told you
everything i told you guys over a period
of two years of doing this show happened
all of it happened
it will continue to happen never should
have been there totally the wrong
strategy it was all about [ __ ] making
money and making in those poppy fields
and it was all about those contracts
and they went down there to try to train
and then
oh well the taliban will never take over
we got 300 000 afghanis with the best
milit u.s army equipment the best
training they just threw all that [ __ ]
down and [ __ ] let the taliban come in
why
because the taliban was the rightful
government
the government we were propping up was a
puppet government the people didn't
support that they supported the taliban
that's who that's who they are
you can't change people
you get if you you just can't
not let them live and if you kill them
all you can change them but you if
you're not gonna do that leave people to
[ __ ] alone it's just a
it goes back when i was in the service
we were refusing mission my units were
refusing missions
that ended up being debacles
just like operation restore hope
somalia [ __ ] joke
it went just like we said it was gonna
go you go in there
they're gonna steal the food you shoot
some of them they'll all turn against
you
and that's exactly what happened
nation building is a [ __ ] joke it
can't happen
they just
you're a foreigner you can't go into
their land and tell them what to do
you wouldn't put up with it neither do
they
that's a moral of the story and it's
kind of like what japan was about
in certain ways you know they were all a
little warring factions and they fought
each other they were all japanese but
not the japanese you know
there were different factions of
japanese they didn't see themselves as a
well they were japanese families and
clans like extended plans right there
wasn't any unity not until there was an
external
threat
and they had to invent an external
threat with china
you know which they talk about it a bit
in this movie and they got their asses
kicked in korea but this went that went
on for a long long time yeah because
they were trying to go through korea and
when he didn't really have to
no he just got got it in his head that
i'm gonna go conquer china because he
got too big for his britches i guess but
you had to go through korea to do that
and korea's like yeah no
i think there was a i think there was
another motive
peace couldn't come to japan because
they just had so many goddamn armed
armies
and different factions
the war against china was a way of
getting rid of all of his opponent's
armies i think
like let's get these guys out of the
[ __ ] let's get them out of japan
it'll be safer in japan if these armies
are doing something somewhere else
and maybe we'll gain some land but maybe
not maybe just those soldiers would be
killed
and the past will die along with them
that may have been the thinking but he
had syphilis later on his thinking
probably wasn't real clear to begin with
yeah he kind of went uh i think it a
little bit
i think it might be lally imagine if you
if you were
if you were fighting the japanese and
the germans and you didn't kill all the
japanese and the germans they just kind
of
made peace with you they would still be
around this and they would still be a
threat if you were an american so let's
try to get the japanese and the germans
to go fight russia maybe russia will
kill him for us i think that's what he
was thinking
it could have been although like i said
he didn't really entirely seem like he
was in his right mind either
because he made like some really like
kind of batshit decisions i think it was
just a vague concept he had
let's get him out of here and maybe
we'll gain something yeah they're
killing off and we don't deal with them
anymore
but it's just and my armies will stay
here and i'll be the strongest army and
[ __ ] all these provinces will listen
to me
i think that's what it was
yeah well and like i said it does seem
also that
you know once you get like a little bit
of success you know
you know just like oh i have all this
power i am asked all this it's like they
just want more and more it's kind of
like we were talking about yesterday we
were talking about cocaine cowboys where
it's like the dude had 100 million
dollars he could have stopped because he
hadn't got caught yet but he's like no i
just know i need a billion so it's kind
of like hey i took over half of the
country why don't i take over the other
it's like they can't stop it's like i
don't know it just gets to a point where
well with the cocaine cowboys if you
spend a million dollars a month that 10
million dollars or 100 million dollars
nothing that's only 100 months you can't
retire on that that's what they're
thinking right maybe like retire like a
normal person but you know
[Laughter]
i could not only retire on it i could
like leave a bunch after i was dead i
don't think i don't think i could spend
it all
yeah but
i don't want a lot of that [ __ ] that
they buy with it this is a great series
hopefully they'll come up with some more
the big loser of the story would have
been
out of this whole story was korea
having lived in korea even in the 90s
and early 90s korea is still traumatized
over all this
for [ __ ] thousands of years korea was
caught in between
china and [ __ ] japan that's gotta
suck a little bit they constantly killed
each other
they were
stuck between a hammer and an anvil
constantly and they couldn't side with
the japanese or the chinese would attack
them and they couldn't side with the
japanese or the chinese would attack
that's what i mean you're kind of [ __ ]
yep they would just sit there
caught between a rock and a hard place
and that that forged this very special
kind of people man the koreans are
[ __ ] tough
the toughest stuff of all those north
koreans
north koreans are [ __ ] insane
now they're not quite the same people
they were
you know
their their government has whittled them
down to about nothing but they do have
willpower
amazing willpower
well that kind of i mean even going back
to the show it's just kind of like the
campaign where hey i'm going to take
over like i took over most of japan now
i'm going to take over china too oh and
korea is kind of in the way we'll figure
that out we'll get and then they start
marching and the koreans are like yeah
and then like they started fighting back
and it's almost like they were surprised
yeah like you know what i mean and it
was fighting us yeah and it was just
like and it wasn't even like always
soldiers it was just like regular ass
people like farmers and [ __ ] they're
like oh no bro this is not happening
yeah everywhere they went they had
people throwing [ __ ] at them
yeah that's which like i said you know
that's what you would expect well it had
never been done before
it was an amphibious invasion of another
of another country
and i don't think well it had been done
maybe
rome did it to carthage but that wasn't
very far away
and
rome could get to carthage by land if it
really wanted to it could go around the
sea
rome one though um and that was more of
a naval battle this was a ground battle
like like d-day like d-day yeah and uh
you know japan didn't have the
experience
they were learning as they were going
real hard to keep an army a large army
in the field when there's a body of
water in between you and them
it just is well this is kind of like in
another way this is an interesting
series too because not only is it
sort of right around the time period
where they were moving to firearms yeah
um but also you know even samurai and
stuff like that
but also there was a lot of um battle
tactics that were used during this time
period that hadn't really been used
before so they go kind of a lot of into
that kind of stuff and that kind of
stuff is like really interesting too
like you know like the one night raid
that that one army did like and that you
know and that hadn't really been done
before either because it was kind of
like
um you know
you're supposed to
come out and battle like you know like
like you do um and then nobody had ever
apparently that they recorded at least
like snuck up on somebody when they were
like in a camp and just like wiped a
bunch of them out louie's mentioning uh
that we learned nothing in vietnam
you know talk about afghanistan and talk
about the mongols and he's also talking
about [ __ ] carthage
yeah
um
it's been said for a long time that
afghanistan is a place is the graveyard
of empires and i got a feeling that's
going to come true
the graveyard of empires
right after soviet union
lost their [ __ ] in afghanistan it broke
apart and [ __ ] america is [ __ ]
right
it won't be the end of the states
america hasn't a second the second wall
of defense the state governments are
doing real good but the the federal
government
i don't know
doesn't look good
um i think um and i and i'm not alone in
saying this a lot of the experts are
saying that this looks like
the final stages of a dying empire
and the time about 200 years
and just the situations the
the bipolar nature of the united states
its uh
porous borders
uh crumbling
infrastructure um totalitarianism
disease if that's what you want to call
it
mind fuckage
this is ripe
well what's happened
the problem with afghanistan usually
what happens is that soldiers do not
join losing armies
so
it follows that the next stage would be
the army evaporates
that's probably what will happen they
are already having recruitment problems
then they uh then the empire gets
desperate they do things like order
drafts
the drafts don't work then they just
draft in people who they hate
who fight against it the system
uh then there's local rebellions and
uprisings they call the military out and
order them to attack civilians and the
military says no and then it just
vanishes everybody goes home
same thing happened in the soviet union
soviet union went down they were yelling
and screaming threatening to throw
people in prisons
ordering invisible armies around that
just vanished and it just
they vanished
and
man
that's what it looks like to me
but we'll see i think it might be months
away
maybe a year or two hard to say
but um usually by the time something
like that happens
it's seen as a good thing instead of a
bad thing because they usually empires
usually go out in a blaze of insanity
and the general public doesn't want it
to be around anymore and then
sanity kind of comes back into play
and um
uh
breakaway republics and new unions
that's usually what happens
but we'll see
okay um anything else you want to talk
about this series
yeah well i mean i should you know i
just wanted everybody to like watch it
because it was like really good it's
like it's really really well made and um
like i said
i kind of feel like they're gonna do
they might continue it like i said
because this covers a pretty brief i
mean it covers a very historic
historically significant uh time period
but it really only covers about what 50
60 years something like that maybe a
little bit more than that maybe 75 years
there's plenty more story to tell that's
what i'm saying i mean it basically it
covers it kind of focuses on um
oda nobunaga
he's kind of like the first guy like
somebody can like compare him to vlad
the impaler which he was a little bit
like that um
toyatomi hidayashi
and uh tokugawa ieyasu and that's kind
of how like it ends up with that guy so
it covers like that whole period like
all the battles that happened during
that period like essentially like the
unification of japan from a bunch of
you know warring factions and clans into
like one country
um and all of the struggles that happen
and like i said it's um i like that they
did like the reenactments it looked like
they tried to make it you know period
accurate it looks really nice all the
battle reenactments lots and lots of uh
it's pretty gory
you know um you know lots of beheading
lots of disemboweling [ __ ] like that
yeah uh you know so so if you're into
that but yeah it's you know it's it's
kind of like
i guess it's something like you would
see on the history channel back when the
history channel was good but
i think it's considerably better than
that it seems like a lot more elevated
it seemed like like i really liked
i really liked the look of it i liked
the aesthetic of it because it looked
like somebody really put a lot of time
and effort particularly into like the
animation
yeah it's like really really nice
looking if you ask me in my opinion when
you're talking about historical
uh
historical uh documentaries that are
this is the way to do it you do it in a
series you do it at an epic scale it's
like watching game of thrones or
something that's pretty much exactly
what this was like and it has to be real
artistic this is this is the way you do
a historical documentary
well see that's one of the best things
about entertainment in general nowadays
is i like that everything is going to
more long form
because you definitely need that i mean
tammy sent me the thing the other day
about um the guy that's going to be
playing uh lestat in the new
vampire chronicles series that they're
doing like he's yeah he looks like
this looks like it's gonna be good it's
an australian dude but um
yeah i said see it's things like that
any kind of like i'm not saying that
like there's some stories are obviously
better told in a movie just like some
stories are better told in the short
story some stories are better told in
the novel but
[ __ ] that's like three four or five
books long you know history that's this
many years long at this complicated with
this many
warring factions and clans and
characters and things you really need
some room to breathe and like stretch
that out so you can go into the context
a lot more so it's not rushed i mean if
they had tried yeah it's possible you
could make a documentary about this time
period that was 45 minutes long but it
wouldn't be as fun to watch it wouldn't
be as entertaining i don't think because
this one really like drills down into
all the kind of
what i liked about it is that they let
they kind of let people
know that
warrior kings that's kind of what
daimyos were
we're [ __ ] nuts and and you know just
because you were a [ __ ] nut doesn't
mean you're doomed to fail the biggest
[ __ ] nut there [ __ ] basically
unified
unified japan he couldn't hold on to it
somebody else replaced him yeah but he
did a lot of the heavy lifting in the
early part of it
and because he was just violent
and uh
violent people were scared of him
it's effective short term not really
long term yeah like i said it bit him in
the ass in the end yeah but in the short
term you can have you know it's the same
thing with mafias and mafia dots
in the long run though once the ball's
rolling you don't have to be that way
you want to start being kind of
magnanimous and [ __ ] virtuous and you
want to kind of have mercy on people
which the best leaders would do they
would call guys to him to grill them you
know they call the vanquished daimyo
make him report they'd report
fully ready to die you know dressed in
their death robes white death robes
ready to ready to commit supuku
and uh then they just
talk with him and say i like you you
know what i mean [ __ ] you're gonna
work for us you know that that is a
better way
because it's actually
you're giving the opponent a peaceful
way out
you don't really want to put some but
the opponent into a quarter where he has
to fight to the death you know
just you lose too many of your own guys
fighting them when you do that yeah
so you want them to you want to try to
bring them on board and make a
coalition's that's a lot better
and i mean can i just say that like
committing ritual disembowelment on
yourself that has to be like the most
hardcore thing ever yeah like i won't be
taken alive and this they can't just
like you know shoot themselves in the
head or you know cut their throat or
something like that
the women cut their throats but even
that's pretty hardcore like as a way to
go but like actually sitting there and
going
and like just cutting all your [ __ ]
they didn't they didn't get this out
holy [ __ ] they didn't get into the into
the into the interest intricacies of
that
the japanese
the way certain things were were worded
in their language they
they believed that the belly is kind of
where the heart of this or the soul of
the person was
and in their
uh in in their language they used back
then to call somebody a coward or a bad
person or a dishonest person or
dishonorable person you basically said
they had a black belly or a black heart
or a black soul
so cutting your belly open was a way of
showing the world that it was not black
yeah that it was that that you were
innocent or you were a good person and
that you were maligned and you're on and
[ __ ] it you're on the way out
they didn't talk about that and they
also didn't really let the audience know
that
seppuku or [ __ ] ritual
disembowelment was not a quick death
they took them 12 sometimes 18 hours to
die
so the death was almost kind of like
crucifixion
you're saying there you know you you
stayed there in agony and showed
everybody you know that you're you're
internal you're innards and pulling them
out you know see [ __ ] [ __ ] you all off
there's nothing wrong with me i i did
the right thing you know
that's that's you know a i'm a good
person it's virtue signal
like really really hardcore right
well let's say i said you know the
western equivalent would be to crucify
yourself yeah you know that's
like that
and uh which is also pretty hardcore
yeah pretty hardcore too that took days
yeah
but uh
no i think [ __ ]
would be worse yeah i think it would be
there was like some people there's all
these japanese stories that were handed
down of what dudes did after they
disemboweled themselves did they take
the guts out and lay it out
yeah did guys reach up and try to
[ __ ] pierce their own hearts weird
[ __ ] like that
it was i don't know it may be legendary
yeah it's like can you [ __ ] imagine i
mean you'd think that you would lose so
much blood that you would just go into
shock but maybe not no your abdominal
wall
probably you know i mean wouldn't bleed
all that much i mean they cut into there
those swords were very sharp like a
scalpel yeah that's true so what you
know you know if you had a real high
quality sword you could get in there
like you were doing surgery on yourself
but it was a big show you know big
production
the women had an easy way out which is
just they just take a small
a relative relatively easy way that was
considered
yeah they just wrapped a damn silk cloth
around a blade and [ __ ] just did that
on their throat
and that was the quick way out and like
i said those blades are very sharp so it
must be like a straight razor
you wouldn't feel much pain probably if
you did it quickly
because i think you can see all that
you know didn't lady cha-cha do that
yeah i think she did yeah yeah i don't
know why it's because her name is lady
cha-cha that's why i remembered he was
just she was ideally quite a woman
yeah they did talk about i mean this is
mostly a sausage fest but they did talk
about like some of the wives and
concubines that did like some
did some [ __ ] but like i said it's just
funny because well it's not funny but
it's just like it's kind of like ancient
rome in the sense that you know um hey
i want you know i don't have an air or i
want this person to be my ear so i'm
just gonna bump off all these other
people like all these other relatives
that might stand in the way they just
like had no absolutely no compunction
about doing it yeah now they talked
about the imperial palace and the
emperor the emperor was kind of like a
spiritual figure he's kind of like the
pope he didn't really have any armies he
didn't have his own
didn't really have any power other than
political kind of like social power
um and he had a court underneath him
and guys were have guys who were bad ass
warlords who didn't who came from
you know peasant stock
to become shogun you know what i mean
you'd have to get falsified documents
saying that you came from some
royal family
and the uh
the courts would [ __ ] help you fake
that if if you impressed him enough
which is
funny because even in japan there was
corruption it'd be like you know
faking u.s citizenship to become a
president or something or faking you
know
just to kind of corrupt inventing laws
so you can steal money that [ __ ] goes
all the way back to that to that period
and rome
well yeah like i said humans are humans
yeah and i'm watching they do the same
they pull the same shenanigans yeah i'm
watching i'm watching the series and i'm
like there's
and everything that they're that their
daimyos are doing and and there's so
many modern analogies you're like yeah
okay well yeah like yeah
humans don't really change all that much
[ __ ] it's the same kind of [ __ ] that's
going on back then yeah but i think
that's why people are like so
entertained by this type of stuff
because yeah you know you can see modern
equivalents because people are not
really they didn't change that much no
yes that's a problem you see
whenever you whenever you start dealing
with people who cannot
really
let's just say ideologies have to
survive human nature
if you believe in things that are just
contrary to the world as it is it ain't
gonna make it and
because people just kind of
people are what they are you can't make
a per you can't make people something
that they're not
and it's just it's demonstrated over and
over again in history
you know which is probably why they want
to replace everybody with damn robots
because uh
if i was rich and all powerful i'd want
to get rid of you [ __ ] i couldn't trust
you
just look at history
so i'm assuming that they're trying to
get rid of us
because i would
i'd be like man they're going to take
all my money and all my power and i'm
not really making any profit off these
people
we got to [ __ ] depopulate this [ __ ]
and there's just so much of the [ __ ]
that they do looks like that that's what
they're thinking
i just hope
that that's just a [ __ ] what they
would call a conspiracy theory
are they that crazy
maybe
maybe
hard to say
uh okay ridley scott would say yeah
[ __ ] right they are
yeah wayland weyland yutani [ __ ]
corporation wants to run everything
danny rowland ghostface says clones will
happen before robots in my opinion they
might you know to be honest with you and
like i said yeah i don't know
genetically engineered superhumans china
wants them and evidently they have some
captain blairdas says john belushi was a
great and honorable samurai yes he was
yes he was
[ __ ] it's not a vegetable that's
right i forgot yeah
he's one of the greatest samurai of all
time i forgot all about him
holy [ __ ] i want to go watch some old
snl on youtube back when that [ __ ] was
funny
yeah well yeah some of it was funny
not all that was funny even back then it
wasn't all right so uh anything else you
would like to add but yeah this is on
netflix i don't know how long it's been
on there i just noticed a couple weeks
uh but yeah it's called age of samurai
battle for japan yeah this [ __ ] here is
[ __ ] you got to see this it's really
good i was like man i was just like see
this one riveted and they get [ __ ]
lone wolf and cub all six movies you get
those like 70 bucks on blu-ray all seven
movies now it's good six movies [ __ ]
classic [ __ ] movie that and check out
red sun you can see it for free on
youtube with [ __ ]
cowboy samurai movie cowboy samurai yeah
i just watched it a couple days ago [ __ ]
was still good yeah you told me you
watched this yeah
uh tomorrow we're going to be talking
about should i spoil it good stephen
king's graveyard shift
because that what ended up happening was
that in the patreon poll you guys
in the patreon poll for the movie
retrospective it was a three-way [ __ ]
tie okay
so what we're gonna do
so we watched graveyard shift last night
so i'm gonna do a matinee on that
tomorrow we're gonna do a movie
retrospective on witchfinder general
with vincent price
and then we're still gonna have to do
probably a matinee it'll probably be on
sunday for uh vampires from 1971 with a
y like the this muddy one yeah the
lesbian one that's a great one yeah that
yeah it is a good one but uh yeah so
that it was a three-way tie so i said
well we'll we'll get to all of them
eventually but we'll do graveyard shift
tomorrow and then we'll do um
we'll do witch finder general for friday
or thursday if you're a patron
kenshin movies are great they're on
netflix right now i don't know what a
kitchen is
yeah we should look those up yeah we can
look those up in movies okay
yeah we're going out tonight so yeah
we're not gonna be able to watch
anything tonight but we can watch some
stuff tomorrow night i guess
so uh so yeah they say that wolf and cub
criterion collection is on hbo max oh is
it really okay so yeah so if you have
hbo max you want to we have it on uh
david yeah
all right so we will be back
tomorrow talking about some stephen king
adaptations and some giant rats
and uh so have a good rest of your day
we'll see you guys tomorrow afternoon
bye